un bar à michail professions de sécurité
internationales à l'université saint
louis à madrid et spécialiste du
moyen-orient
bonjour barah mikaïl merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france comment
est-ce qu'il faut interpréter cette
reprise de l'aide financière de
washington à la palestine revirement
politique définitif ou simplement
attendu alors à l'autorité palestinienne
je crois qu'il ne faut pas afin tout en
se réjouissant peut-être d'un relatifs
changement de la manière par laquelle
l'administration byden se positionne
vis-à-vis de la question palestinienne
ou du moins vis-à-vis des acteurs
palestiniens des acteurs politiques
palestiniens et de la population
palestinienne
je crois qu'il ne faut pas pour autant
déduire de cette aide octroyée à l'unrwa
et de la rhétorique manié par
l'administration byden sur la nécessaire
solutions à des états il faut pas en
déduire le fait qu'il y aurait un
changement de cap à 180 degrés et c'est
à dire que je crois que au final il est
vrai que l'administration byden essaye
de corriger un peu le tir par rapport
aux extrêmes et aux excès qui avait été
promu et avait été avancé par
l'administration comme précédemment
mais dans le même temps je n'ai pas
l'impression que l'administration bailon
irait jusqu'à on va dire jusqu à
naviguer d'un coup d'un coup de gauche
et jusqu'à jusqu'à aller vers force et
on va dire la nécessité pour les
israéliens et les palestiniens de se
mettre d'accord sur une solution à des
étapes donc dit autrement je crois que
oui baydan sera moins pro israélien dans
les apparences que ne l'a été deux
chambres mais ce n'est pas pour autant
qu'il sera plus pro palestiniens que ne
l'a été obama mais quel dialogue
attendre alors entre
joe biden et le président de l'autorité
palestinienne mahmoud abbas par exemple
est-ce qu'on peut y voir une amorce
visant à revenir sur le plan de paix
proposé par donald trump et son gendre
jared kushner favorable largement israël
avec notamment à l'approbation de
l'annexion à une partie de la
cisjordanie n'ose pas qu'il faut
distinguer la politique d'effet de la
politique des intentions c'est à dire
que la politique des faits c'est le fait
que donald trump a engagé les états unis
sur la question de la reconnaissance de
jérusalem comme capitale d'israël donc
l'administration by donne pourrait
difficilement dire ça c'est derrière
nous contredire ça sent on va dire
envenimer ses relations avec israël donc
en ce sens là je crois qu'il y aura
plutôt une tentative de la part de
l'administration byden d'éviter de
toucher ou d'éviter de se référer de
trop près aux questions qui sont
effectivement polémique et qui de
surcroît s'avère en contradiction avec
le droit international et en
l'occurrence concernant jérusalem en et
touchant trump a pris des ballerines
distances avec les principes du droit
international mais de manière
intéressante si on regarde là la
question de la nécessaire solution de
deux états les états unis l'enfant ni
les états unis ni chang bien sûr dit
même byden ne vont jusqu'à lire nous
avons une référence qui est le droit
international qui est la résolution 242
donc en ce sens là je crois que quand
l'administration byden dit nous voulons
une solution à deux états ça reste
ouvert dans le sens on ne sait pas
quelles seront les frontières on ne sait
pas quelles seront les conditions et le
supposé de tout cela c'est que bien
entendu ce sur une solution à deux états
qui pour sa part je dirais à soirée plus
les demandes d'israël que les demandes
des palestiniens au foot du compte
puisque les israéliens sont la partie
forte mais très honnêtement à ce stade
là il est vraiment trop tôt pour tabler
sur une volonté de l'administration
byden d'engager des tractations pour la
paix je veux dire mahmoud abbas est
malade il faut des conditions qu'on
l'organisation des élections à venir il
faudrait également clarifier les
conditions d'organisation de
négociations il faudrait de meilleures
relations entre les etats-unis et israël
ou entre baida nathaniel natanyahou donc
il faudrait au moins un mandat écoulé
pour que l'on puisse vraiment envisager
sérieusement cette question du monde de
mont
tout le monde est donc au niveau des
relations à venir dans les prochains
jours les prochaines semaines des
prochains mois à quoi faut-il s'attendre
entre joe biden et l'autorité
palestinienne est entre joe biden et
benyamin nétanyahou entre washington et
israël simple coup de froid passage et
donc selon vous et pas de profondes
divergences c'est ça alors déjà bien
entendu il faudra voir ce qu'il en sera
de la donne israélienne dans un compte
dans un contexte dans lequel il reste un
peu moins de 28 jours à benyamin
netanyahu pour former un gouvernement
donc là il ya quand même s'il ya une
ouverture vers certaines incertitudes
d'incertitudes même si elles sont assez
limitées aux contrôles et dans le même
temps
mais pour le reste si nathalie on reste
premier ministre il y aura bien sûr des
tensions des accords entre lui et
l'administration by donne ça va durer
quelques semaines voire quelques mois
mais ce n'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau souvenez vous des deux mandats
de l'administration obama
souvenez-vous du second mandat de
l'administration obama en particulier
obama et netanyahu se détester ce n'est
pas pour autant qu'on a eu de rupture de
relations
ce n'est pas pour autant que israël a
été défavorisé dans ses différentes
demandes et ses différentes
revendications
donc en ce sens là je crois que le gros
du travail ce serait si jamais
l'administration by dane est déterminé à
avancer sur le dossier israélo
palestinien
ce serait pour elle de trouver la
manière de convaincre les israéliens de
la nécessité d'avancer sur ce dossier
tout en sachant que les israéliens sont
aussi remontés concernant les négations
négociations sur le nucléaire iranien
donc dit autrement ma prochaine question
sur le nucléaire iranien à quid de
washington dans le jcp au a également
c'est cet accord signé en 2015 à vienne
lesquelles l'administration tron s'était
retirée de manière unilatérale en 2018
washington va t'il réellement revenir et
si oui quelles conséquences avec israël
qui est fermement opposé à l'iran alors
du moins d'après ce que l'on voit et il
refait il ya des négociations en cours
les états unis ne participent pas mais
robert mallet entre autres aux hauts
représentants américains sont dans le
coin sont dans des hôtels qu'ils ont
fait ils sont juste à côté de cette
négociation donc il ya quelque chose qui
est en cours bien entendu mais dans le
même temps
je crois qu'il ne faut pas avoir pour
critère on va dire l'agitation où les
craintes israéliennes parce que les
craintes israéliennes seront toujours
présentes les israéliens ne veulent pas
d'accord je crois que côté américain il
ya une volonté d'apaiser la situation
avec l'iran mais je doute fort que que
plomb et des percées qui puisse aller au
delà de ce que l'administration obama
elle-même avait accompli sur ce dossier
est on pour dire les choses autrement je
crois que pour l'instant
l'administration by donne essaye de s'en
tenir à certains à certaines limites en
entrant pas directement dans des
négociations avec l'iran mais regardez
les premières déclarations qui nous
viennent qui vient de nous parvenir de
la part du président iranien concernant
ces différentes avancées
on voit bien que les iraniens sont
plutôt satisfaits et sont plutôt
rassurés devant la manière par laquelle
selon laquelle se profile des choses
dedans
d'une certaine manière qu'est ce que
cela veut dire ça veut dire que la
confrontation qu'avaient joué john tu ne
seras plus à l'ordre du jour mais nous
nous attendons pas pour autant à ce que
l'on aille vers une complète
normalisation bien sûr des relations
américano-iraniennes je crois que ce
sont les termes d'un accord sur le
nucléaire iranien qui monte petit à
petit s'installer mais il restera à voir
si elles intégreront le on va dire la
limite où le 6e attendront le degré que
obama avait atteint son époque ce qui à
mon avis n'est pas non plus gagné
d'avancé merci à michail d'abord les
prenez une question je rappelle que vous
êtes professeur de sécurité
internationales à l'université saint
louis à madrid et spécialiste du
moyen-orient